I don't consider high value if everybody
else can have you why would you want
something that everybody else can have
don't marry the men that are most likely
to cheat if you don't want to be cheated
on why would you let your girl have a
straight up marketing billboard on the
internet there's no man that doesn't
want to cheat on his way um loyalty than
love at the end of the day
um to start we are going to do your name
your age your relationship status and a
fun fact about yourself starting here go
around and then we'll do the second row
okay hey guys I'm Kyra I'm 22. I'm
single and a fun fact I'm gonna say I
have never been in a relationship before
yeah that's my fun fact
uh my name is Rudy but everybody calls
me real I am 20.
it's a bit complicated and a fun fact
about me what's complicated about it can
I be in on the no no how much time do
you actually have no okay so is this
like you guys are you guys are hooking
up we've known each other for a while
and it's just in that difficult stage
but you know so you've been going on
dates and stuff or you've known them for
years and he's getting out the friend
zone no we've been through all of that
we've had the waves but you know things
happen things got skewed with but we're
just what what happened let me in let me
in I just I want to be a no you're gonna
make me cry no
um
like three minutes in no I moved here
Manchester uh to study so it was that
distance that kind of long distance
thing you know messages got skew where
things got changed and
um
do you know what I mean that kind of
vibe so it's complicated but a fun fact
about me I am actually double jointed in
this thumb if you can see on the camera
it kind of bends like this so like I'll
try that at home if you can't do it I'll
teach you how to do it but yeah that is
a fun fact please don't teach me
okay good I'm Amira and I'm 21
um I'm single
um and a fun fact about me is I want to
learn how to do that I want to know what
room
oh go ahead
um I'm Cecilia I'm 21 as well about to
be 22. I'm single and fun fact about me
um I'm South American
we have a young Couch today but
everyone's under what 23 on the couch
yeah yeah okay
um
Justin do you want to go sure my name is
Justin 37 wouldn't you like to know and
no fun facts for now
oh
I'm Troy 47 single and I once went out
to party in London and I woke up two
days later in Vegas
wow
from London to Vegas
um I think it was just excessive alcohol
and the bun homie of the spirit of the
occasion uh it was pretty wild though I
woke up and I was like where the hell am
I and um turned out to be Vegas so yeah
it was a good night
that's crazy
um go ahead hi my name is Regina I'm 28.
I'm single and the fun fact about me
it's um I don't know keep keep watching
okay that's how I flooded in my fun fact
evil but my name is Iman
um I'm 21 and I'm single and a fun fact
about me is
um
I can juggle oranges
that is fun yeah it's a good party trick
yeah yeah
how do you juggle I'm three three yeah
that's it
for the floor okay yeah so we got some
room for improvement you can get to
maybe six someday or yeah maybe yeah or
like other objects okay
hey guys I'm Alex I am 28 from fact
about me is I'm an avid salsa and
bachata kizomba dancer oh that's cool
okay so today's topic
is modern women should stay if high
value men cheat
so there was a certain footballer that
is in the news
and he's in the news because his wife
divorced him for cheating oh yeah
however
all of the money was in his mom his
mom's name
so in hindsight being 20 20
knowing that he was taking fully 100
taking care of her
should she have stayed
why don't we start with the couch
um and then we'll get we'll get the
women's opinions and then we'll get the
men's so start here
I don't know I think I think it's all
about the principal
I get that it's like 2020 free
I get the I don't know where we're
moving towards more liberal times you've
got to do what you've got to do but I
just feel like
oh I just if it was me I wouldn't want
to know things like that I wouldn't I
wouldn't want to know that it was coming
I don't know I feel like I need a yes or
no I need a yes or no are you are you
team stay or team go
I think go go yeah it's not very Mandy
and not go it's not manly to cheat no it
I guess you don't think it's manly to
sleep with multiple women
it's like a masculine trait
I guess so I you know what the more I
hear it the more I feel like you know
what I'm gonna have to accept that if I
want a high value man if yeah if I want
a man they're gonna exercise their
options how do I feel about that I don't
know but it I guess it seems like
the reality that we live in
so I I don't know it's hard do you think
she should date a footballer and expect
him to be faithful is that a good bet
is it do you know what you know what I
think this might be my idea of a high
value man I don't know about everyone
else's opinion but my idea of a high
value man is that you have to be so
certain in yourself and closed off
because I don't consider high value if
everybody else can have you yeah because
why would you want something that
everybody else can have that's not
special do you know what I mean do you
see what I mean so then why do women
keep sleeping with them
if women in general don't even think of
them knowing that he's a cheater a
Serial cheater do you think women sleep
with Drake and are worried about his
monogamy you think Drake has a shortage
of women
slide oh
General high value men do tend to cheat
and women don't care
I think it comes down to the type of guy
that person is if you're that guy saying
yeah I've had I'm high valued I'm high
valued are you though are you yes
usually if they're rich enough and
famous enough and successful or not yeah
that's when you decide is high value
meaning your success what you can
provide who you can protect what you can
do for your family what car you drive
what house you live in or is high value
the way you're raised the work the
morals your mum brought you up in I
would say it's the the men that are the
men that women pick
yeah it's the market it's demanding
Supply isn't it you know you've got to
look at what what does the market demand
if everybody if all these women want to
sleep with Drake then regardless of what
we may think of that that demand would
indicate that Drake is high value the
spot of alert I'm a sex worker
so that means I get paid two
have men that cheat on their wives or oh
wow or their girlfriends and I get them
every single day
most of the desired like they do it with
a sex worker because they feel like
there's no there's no strings attached
to it and uh
there a lot most of the time like I
don't even see like the what's a picture
on their number because they have a wife
and kids
but then when they come to you and then
they feel like too like um comfortable
enough they're gonna tell you even like
the story of their life
and most of the time like there's like a
very lonely man inside of a marriage hmm
I'm not saying like cheating it's a good
thing because it's not I've been in a
relationship and I've been cheated as
well even though I'm a sex worker and
even like my my job has been used
against me
from my exes like I was like oh yeah you
shouldn't be caring because you're a sex
worker
so that's why I'm cheating oh that's why
I'm having like a free time around I
think that's unfair
um I mean it's unfairs from my point of
view yes because as I said as I said
it's my job and like if I go into a
relationship to get to know someone here
I always like a disclaimer I'm this this
is me so you let them know up front yeah
always
but you're still having sex at work
yeah but like that's my job yeah but it
doesn't take away that you're sleeping
with other people yeah but I get paid no
so I had um a question more about the
the men that cheat on their wives yeah
but that's why would you would you say
those men um
would you are they like what percent
would you say are in like sexless
marriages
out of every like maybe like around the
75 percent really yeah three out of four
because like of most of the time he's
like oh we've got kids
and after the third Keys like um they're
what the sparkle wasn't there anymore
and then she stopped sleeping with him
or it's mutual it's mutual most of the
time then like in the most of cases like
it's a her not
feeling comfortable with herself enough
to go to the men most of the time as
well because like they get
you know like I think like the selfish
theme of a woman depends as well because
on the environment you've got at home
like yeah I need to love myself to love
someone else but like if as well like
the man with uh with whom I'm living
with
doesn't make me feel love
I agree with that I think that's why my
team go I think I'm team go because I
think as a woman if you can sense that
your man isn't being faithful
no matter how much self-love we give
ourselves it we automatically think
what's wrong with me why am I not good
enough what do I what does she have that
I don't this this all these thoughts run
through our brain and that knocks your
confidence so obviously like you can't
be in a happy home in a happy
environment no matter what your husband
brings to the table that does something
to a person mentally and that's why I'm
just team girl sorry Bianca what about
you
I mean I agree with Rue
um in terms of like a high value man I
think it depends on what you call like
class that as because if you're going
around saying I'm a high value man are
you really if you're just going around
doing anything that you would want to do
I feel like yeah you still are they
still are high value men no they still
are yeah but so I feel like are you
really and the answer is yes they still
are but who says this the women by
picking them through sex
I get that sometimes women don't
they're extremely clear
I just don't so I would say like if
Drake went out and said I'm a high value
man I would say yes he is because he has
a plethora of women
but then it goes back to what you deem a
high-valued man yeah but you're you're
just trying to shift the definition of
high value man aren't you you're trying
to make it more cuddly and friendly like
oh he's a really nice guy he's like
super honorable and blah blah blah but
but the truth of the matter is like as
Pearl said I mean if the market is
selecting for guys like that like Drake
that that indicates that he's high value
okay in the definition that's most
commonly accepted okay so if you revert
it back to like say say you have a
daughter right she turns 18 she comes to
you and says Dad listen I've started
dating this guy things happen you he's
dating whoever he's sleeping with
whoever would you deem him a high value
fan
I'm sure I wouldn't be happy about that
in that scenario but that doesn't that
doesn't detract from the fact that in
terms of societally that dude is still
gonna be if he was Drake or somebody
like that he's still gonna be regarded
generally as high value I mean my
feelings is the father would not really
undermine that if my daughter came home
with Drake or I don't know which one
that's so that's so well I will check
her hand like
or was dating a footballer yeah I would
say what did you expect like yeah it's
like you see them in the media they all
cheat usually yeah
um typically when men can't cheat they
do
and um I don't know why you would expect
a man that has beautiful women thrown at
him every single day to be faithful and
if you don't want that why would you
pick a footballer I don't understand
that why did you pick that I do agree
with that but I think it's more of the
fact that if you're choosing to marry
someone if you know that you want to be
living a certain life why would you
accept and like be like closed off but
you're not actually closed off what do
you mean like if you're going to choose
to marry someone as a footballer if
you're going to marry someone don't
marry them if you know that you want to
live a different life no now they call
themselves polyamorous yeah but I would
say don't marry the men that are most
likely to cheat if you don't want to be
cheated on okay so why pick them how
value men don't have to be polyamorous
if you switch it round right exactly and
say okay the woman the woman is sleeping
with so many different men she's a horse
would that man exactly she's not high
value she's a [__] she's a [__] yeah
why is it called why is it called value
if like if your C point of loads of
different women then your values aren't
actually High well in my book there's
like values it's valuable it's valuable
yeah it's valuable it's not with high
value is valuable it's valuable but even
you know like um high value men so it's
like okay women want to sleep with high
value men and whatever whatever this
high value in this Society is I'll give
you I'll give you the definition really
quick okay of course just so and this is
from Kevin Samuels this was his
definition so you know it's going to be
different based on who you talk to I
would say it's the women or the men that
women pick but 10K a month other men
must accept you as high value you have
to have a network of high value men you
have to be visibility LinkedIn level and
you have to be useful to others in the
group okay so that's that's what sorry
go ahead finish it okay cool so I'm not
gonna even say high value when I'm
saying this but if you're a woman and
you know that the man is sleeping with
um lots of women and he's got a lot of
money more time I'm that girl getting
into that relationship is not looking
for relationship she's also looking for
something out of it because if you know
the man's gonna be sleeping with
multiple women and he's got money you'll
be having sex with him maybe for the
money that's why when they get kids and
they feel secure and it's like we've got
a family you're saying a lot of them
feel lonely because they're not having
sex with them anymore because you're
gonna stay and you're still gonna give
me money you're still going to bring
your high value and you can have sex
with other women and I don't care
because I don't actually love you
so that's why I feel these high values
I'd like to make an argument the men
that sleep with you are not high value
they're just Rich uh well because a high
value man can go out and get it his damn
self you got to pay you well like if I'm
being fails pay my bills like like a
high value man trips over women yeah
they don't they don't have to do [__] on
the side so why why does a high value
man need so many women because it's so
high value because that's how men are
they don't do it because it makes them
feel better see people get this [__]
up they try to guilt men but like and
say oh you're insecure one second they
say oh you're insecure you got to sleep
with all these women to get validation
[__] men like to [__] let's let's
yeah we all know let's call it space
yeah it's not like because what women
try to do is they try to guilt a man
into acting the right way like oh I
would this girl
I wouldn't pick um and I completely
understand that but but my argument to
that is if you were head over heels in
love and you had genuine desire for that
man as bad as it might hurt you you
would stay and so would everybody on
that couch and that is true
situation because as much as you hate
him for doing it you know deep down if
you were dating some slump he would do
it if he could and women misinterpret
the inability to get a woman for loyalty
and it's [__] so let's call spade a
spade it's true yeah I don't think I'm a
mistake the inability I think they know
of course absolutely no it's a [__] test
they're like oh a good man would do this
and this and if the dude's a [__]
enough to give in to it then they got
him but the truth is right after that
they get enough of him after a few years
of marriage they end up texting a high
value man behind her back or his back or
either South America they just go to
something like um My Religion for
example they do something called um
sweetening of the person
um so I'm South American obviously I'm
from Venezuela and my religion is
which is a phalange of the spiritually
sticker be the beliefs and stuff like
that so like oh yeah I'm from the famous
religion of macombas
and I had and I had so many women coming
to me because I read tarot card I read
tarots and everything
and I've had oh yeah no my my husband is
cheating on me I'm gonna do like that
there's some women that they don't use
judgment because like I am completely
against it yeah but the crazy thing half
of those women have open Instagram
accounts with thought pictures on them
the same women that complain about being
cheated on get attention from men all
the time I know so it's like a lot of
times like women will act like we're so
much better than men because you know
they cheated maybe we didn't in a
relationship but a lot of times we cheat
in a different way we cheat by getting
attention from men but the get out
clause is always it wasn't physical or
not right the get out close is always
well yeah but she didn't do anything
physically he did but I agree with you I
just I don't think it matters no I don't
think about this either but I'm just
saying Society that's that's their get
out of clothes you ever look at Haley
Bieber's Instagram account this is Haley
Beaver this woman bagged the guy that
every girl want who like come on who had
a crush on Justin and their teenage okay
yeah
if it was okay I'm tall so it wasn't me
but I knew half the girls did she she
got him and what look at her Instagram
account it's literally ass picture butt
picture lingerie picture and this is the
woman that got the man that everybody
wants well Haley Bieber and Justin's
relationship that was completely
formulated like if you see the clips on
YouTube and the crazy sightings that
they were together they were never like
five meters away from each other for
throughout the whole childhood but I
think going back to this picture thing
on Instagram if you are a genuinely
pretty girl and you give off those nice
Vibes you are gonna get those attention
from those males but it's your choice
whether you feed it or not yeah true
that's it that's feeding it and then
you're part of the problem because you
fed it they shouldn't feel comfortable
enough
to even do that with you yeah but isn't
it feeding it to post those pictures and
to have an open Instagram account where
it meant any man can message you agreed
but you can't go down the path of saying
I'm posting this to feel good to do good
he's [__] those girls to feel good
it's empowering him you know I argue
that that's Justin's fault not her fault
because if he had his frame correctly in
his house that [__] would not happen
what what she wouldn't disrespect him
like that if he called for more from her
so is Justin Bieber's fault not hers you
think it's a disrespect type damn right
I think it's disrespect I don't think he
knows how to manage his girl you know
and create leadership in the household
there's no [__] way a man should
allow that [__] and if he does it might
be leadership he just doesn't care about
that maybe he's secure enough I think I
think he's racing no I don't think it's
a security thing I think his lack of
Consciousness I don't think he
understands what's going on I agree with
that I think I think men should provide
um so you do think there's like secure
relationships posting them type of
things I can do it talking to yourself
so you don't think there's like secure
relationships posting them things and
feeling confident about each other it's
not about security it's just about why
would you let your girl have a straight
up marketing billboard of her ass on the
internet
yeah it's absolute [__] and if he
had the right frame with her and she was
truly in love with him she was happy to
take that [__] down that is true and
most men don't see that me and pearl
were talking earlier about a
relationship the God said that
everything was good for the first seven
years and it's those little things right
there that that man didn't see because
he's like oh well she slept with another
dude well there's also the girls trip
there was also the post on Instagram
there was also the call from her High
School boyfriend that she got in the
middle of the night no bro she's been
telling you the whole time your frame's
off then you got cheated on because she
doesn't respect you wait what do you
mean girls trip
like she went on a girl's trip to Vegas
yeah that's not something you'd allow no
no if your girl's in love with you and
truly in love with you she doesn't even
want to go on a girls trip why okay so
posting pictures as a woman online I
can't do that but you can go and sleep
with multiple women because you're high
value
you don't have to stay
I'll replace you you don't have to call
yourself high value men I I'm not this
first of all I hate Alpha Beta high
value all that [__] any man that's
really about his business does not go by
that and I I personally will never call
myself how about you I think it's cringy
as [__] what I will say is and I respect
your opinion and you're actually saying
something that is good in this right
moment because like
please you're not defining yourself
something you're not yeah
[Laughter]
all right so but but what I am saying is
is regardless of how how you place me in
the world I would say this about myself
or any other person that has a girl that
he cares about if her ass and titties
are on the internet that is an active
billboard of marketing to get attention
from other men and possibly through
hypergamy transition away from you to
someone else and if she truly loves you
she will take that [__] down and when
you think about it as well it's the
first time really in human history that
this has happened on such a scale isn't
it if you think about women even a few
well 20 15 20 years ago when was it
there were no women who were who were
putting themselves publicly in that
manner aside possibly from celebrities
which is a slightly different case but
now everyone's got an Instagram account
it's really unprecedented in human
history isn't that what it's it's all
about these days though it's dealing
with reality as it is it's we live in a
day and age where women can make money
off of being on social media
um you know taking provocative pictures
and like that and where you know it's
desirable for men to like have loads of
women chasing after them isn't that it's
not it's not like yeah but it's like
what do you want to deal with those
women as a guy like why would you want
to deal with a girl that's in the club
every weekend no yeah why would you why
would you want to deal with a girl that
wants to do girls trips while she's in a
relationship yeah I think girls trips is
okay like definitely go with your girls
have a good time that's not saying that
you have to be out in the club sleeping
with whoever but for me in if I was in a
relationship you would not catch one
photo of me with my bum out tits out
nothing like that that [__] that's foul
to me like I don't like that as a woman
and like I know us girls like we've seen
things and been like what she has a
boyfriend though you know she has a
boyfriend she has a man though you know
it's not right and girls encourage each
other to cheat on those traps yeah you
know you're smiling because you're
thinking of something I can see it I can
see it it's funny because I really think
it depends on your friendships that's
why when you get into relationship it's
so important to look at who are these
like who are these man's friends and who
are my friends that when I have when I
get married I hope that my husband he
also has friends that are married and
you know don't want to cheat on their
wives because show me your friends and
I'll show you who you are no man that
doesn't want there's no man that doesn't
want to cheat on his way um I I don't
believe that fact right I'm gonna find a
high value godly man that is what I'm
gonna find it
every of the Old Testament
I'm not talking about a man that just
goes to church I'm talking about a man
that has a relationship with God there's
a big difference and I will find no I
don't want to please because there's a
lot of priests that don't have a
relationship with God they just want to
make money from church but the key word
is you said want every man wants to
cheat that's like asking a man not to be
every guy okay
every every man when they see a hot girl
wants to [__] her come on come on
Natural Instinct yeah but that love is
supposed to take over it's about loving
too yeah you might have the desire but
it's about exactly right going out there
exactly right and when a woman loves a
man she doesn't even see other men
that's so true okay I'm not done though
because a man yeah can love his wife
with all his heart and want nothing more
than be a good father a protector tuck
his children in hold his wife at night
but if you think that he doesn't want to
get [__] on the side you have lost your
mind but why does that side like where
it's truly like if I could snap my
fingers right now and make that feeling
go away I think I'd be worth 10x what
I'm worth
and I would do the deal I would pay a
million dollars to make that thought
that was what I was gonna ask next
isn't it harder for you to be high value
and have sex with so many like women
because people understand a real high
value man doesn't have to chase women
women chase him yeah exactly I know
that's the problem right isn't it I
don't want to be a good man it's in your
face
you see like I don't look I'm not trying
to be disrespectful to you guys I'm just
so it sounds a bit discipline then it
sounds to the discipline of the man it's
in your face every day but at the same
time even though it's hard it's still a
thing where okay cool am I gonna do I'm
gonna have the discipline not to have
sex with this person let me tell you
what happens to a man I do want to
answer your question because I think
it's important government finishes
though
everything that drives a man to get out
of bed and work his ass off is generally
around the thought of sex just so you
know men build then invent build and
maintain society and pursue the women
okay my man works his whole life to get
himself in a certain place financially
physically all these things the man he
becomes and then into that you tell him
you get one woman forever he would tell
you to [__] off it is very very hard
that's why
the real high value man will tell
his girl was up instead of lie like a
[__] coward but that's why that's why
I feel like the missing piece is
actually God because you say the high
value man will do all these things for
sex but a high value man of God he will
be doing all these things because he
wants to put first God first in his
decision say low value what's the
question yeah but he wants to live out
of you man
exactly but and that's a great point if
if you have two men you can pick two men
a low value man that's gonna cheat and a
high value man is going to cheat which
one are you going to pick because they
both will cheat on you it's better to be
single than to be like cheated or then
you're avoiding the question which one
which one would I pick yeah one is going
to give you a better life children love
you be there for you
I wouldn't I didn't want to pick oh you
don't want to I don't want to pick so if
I would be single so you're diverse kids
yeah I'm diverting the questions
at the end of the day
I don't believe every man cheats well
every man doesn't cheat but every Every
Man Has the propensity or the desire to
for variety definitely and that's what I
went to loyalty versus ability yeah I
rather loyalty than love at the end of
the day but I know how men are the end
of the day it's not you're telling me I
have a loyalty than love any day of the
week any day of the month and whenever
loyalty the love what I lie
oh my God okay so do you you would you
would date Jonah Hill a guy that looks
like Jonah Hill he's loyal on my front
preference you know how I know she's
foolish he's loyal every girl on this
couch has a host of men in their
Instagram inbox right now that would
marry them tomorrow and be loyal forever
they don't want those men do you have
men in your inbox of course everyone
does every one of those men I'm not
denying every single girl wants a
certain type of man but at the end of
the day that's he's not gonna whatever
question out of the girls who here have
who's been in a situationship before
I've been in one so one everyone yeah
okay so what were you doing then yes
ridiculous he wasn't loyal to you that's
love of a loyal to you do you know I
don't have to agree with you you know
what though when you are really invested
in someone and you want to put that time
in I completely think that everybody
else is blacked out to me it doesn't
matter what else you bring it doesn't
matter if I'm channeling for that guy
this guy X could come with a gazillion
cars a gazillion houses this and that I
don't care I do not care because I want
that one there and that's the reality
and that's the same reason you won't
leave them that's the reality of it but
but I could be dating a high value man
who has everything in the world if you
cheat on me you're a bum to me sorry
have you ever stayed with someone who
cheated nope never no so other question
um so you said something about uh yeah
you said honesty right so clearly
honesty is not the primary the key kind
of characteristic because you've all got
DMS right so you can all find an honest
a loyal man sorry so
[Music]
you're telling me loyalty is your number
one characteristic I feel like in my
personal wait I have a question he's
five two but loyal yeah I feel like I'm
going to use the most important okay
there we go now we're getting to the
truth like I'm five nine I think I think
women sometimes work like the other way
around they'll tell you the least
important stuff he's
broke he has no job and won't get a job
as well I'm asking what you he's broke
but no job but he's loyal
yeah of course
I'm sorry I'm staying because I would
stay okay
loyalty over anything but it's so funny
it's hard to find a broke man that won't
cheat exactly I feel like broken
do you realize one out of three men are
either virgins or haven't had sex in the
past year
do you realize that you find eighty
percent of men is unattractive not okay
not average you look at eighty percent
of men and you deem them unattractive
yeah you know we only swipe right on
dating apps five percent of the time so
why do women say men are trash because
we're all sleeping with the same ones so
whether you know it or not
you know it or not you're doing it
but they go for the same type of men
they don't learn and I have my own
values I have my own principles but at
the end of the day in a generalized form
women go through the same type of men
and they want to be screaming oh this
this and that but that's the type of man
that you go through in the first place
like yeah probably complain what kind of
what kind of man do you go to though you
haven't answered my question what's the
number one what's the number one
characteristic so you said loyalty which
is capital so let's let's bring that to
the side so we know high is also
important we know success is important
you know their lifestyle is important I
just wanna how do you screen all these
Instagram DMs I just want a genuine
person at the end of the day
the genuine person who's five who's five
two what if he's really far too
obviously there's obviously at the end
of the day
is really awkward you can barely make
eye contact
there's genuine studies for each person
I need a yes or no
very awkward very awkward can barely
maintain eye contact with you but he's
loyal yes or no because I want someone
that can con but I thought the Loyalty
that was the most important thing
but this thing isn't the only thing yeah
there's things that the little things
that come over yeah but to be fair you
did say they said what's your most
important thing and you said loyalty
because it is but clearly it's not
though is it it's the whole relationship
of just the Loyalty that's the thing
there's a lot of factors in relationship
but there's a lot of factors that come
first before loyalty anyway my opinion I
think like no one is loyal anymore
because like most of the time I have
clients that where they that they are
like oh yeah my wife doesn't need too
I'm like do you really think your wife
is doing something else in this moment
like do you think she's at home waiting
for you
um no she's probably getting someone
else on a dating website to do the same
but like the only thing she's doing it
for free you're paying women always know
women always know that we always feel
when something is off it's definitely a
thousand percent true so no so do you
think like so we're talking about
long-term relationships at one point do
you think that a woman's needs from a
man say attention intimacy consistent
like 50 years you're talking about
loyalty right it's the worst thing to
get cheated on do you ever think there's
limitations to that the other thing
there's only so much time a man can give
you is full attention time love intimacy
and you expect him to be monogamous do
you think you're annoying sometimes or
that can fade sometimes
I don't know if I can speak on my side
like for example like my grandfather
he's uh he was because he's not here
anymore and um he was a really really
big man that in Venezuela a really
well-known one and very important but
like at the end of the day he's being
loyal loyal at the front
on paper to my grandmother but then like
at some point when one of my uncles died
he showed up to the to the funeral
saying like oh you know guys I've got in
total 27 kids from different women but
he's always been like true to his kids
like he's always been maintaining them
he's never let them
like being without anything they
everyone has asked for something and he
was there working hard on it and giving
it well that's a great man that is a
great man that is the old style
archetype of the high value man isn't it
yeah yeah I I have a question
um do you guys think that most men would
cheat if given the chance so if let's
say a very very attractive like Margot
Robbie is who I think of
um
Ah that's how they're Crossing girl's
name okay I can't think of her name but
a Margot Robbie level girl came up to
him yeah and said I'll have sex with you
right now right here most men would say
yes of course yeah yeah there's a bear
[__] in the woods yeah
so so is it better to accept men as they
are or try to change them into what we
want them to be you can't change a mind
yeah he's gonna be who he shows but but
you guys when we're having this
conversation the way you're talking it's
like you're trying to change how men are
no no I feel like a man will change for
you if he wants to change yeah
exactly your man has a problem that he's
suffering with but he finds this girl
he's gonna think oh my gosh I need to
change this girl I want this girl in my
life I'm going to change for her but I'm
going to stop that what I'm doing on
this side and I'm this is all I'm gonna
think about so everything that I do from
now is gonna be for that girl and that
is the dream that Disney sold us
I'm a little girl that's
you know but call me naive but that's
what I would like to think you know but
the only thing women want when it comes
down to it the only thing we ask for is
just to be protected and that's it
if you can't protect us and you can't
provide security yeah add that emotional
stability for us we're not bothered
protection from War I need to know that
if I'm out
you know and I come into a problem I
know that it doesn't matter how I act
because I know that I'm going to be
saved because I've got my man there so I
know that he's going to be able to solve
whatever situation happens with me I
need to know that I can come home from
work for a bad day and say babe listen
and just reel it off and I can have that
emotional stability with him ah of
course he wants him to stay loyal she's
still working
you know the truth is you're capping
you've not run into it yet you're too
young but in about 10 years she's gonna
be a ride or die and help him get
threesomes I'm telling you it's going to
happen
like I tried to do it it didn't work I'm
gonna get one of these good ones
do they exist fine yes there's
occasional men that make a lot of money
and don't cheat
but most of y'all aren't gonna get him
okay
is it better to accept men as they are
or change them into what we want them to
be they just don't change them find your
own no no but we remember we we just
established the majority the majority
will not end up with these magical men
that make a lot of money have women
chasing them and then choose not to
cheat most women aren't going to end up
with a guy like that okay PO let me ask
you a question do you think that if
you're deemed more like an attractive
female you run into these problems more
do I think that attractive women run
into cheating more all these all every
problem that we've just discussed do you
think that would happen more as for an
attractive female
or as just someone that's just stated
yeah you know you bang average I I the
reason I the reason I would guess it
happens to attractive women more is
because attractive women get to deal
with the types of men that most women
want more seriously where like the lower
the lower women like unless they have a
really good personality like usually
they're just side chicks yeah no I agree
with that also that's really the problem
you're running into is because you've
not run into a one percent man yet
because if Drake did that to you you
would stay with Drake
you might not like it you'd hop up and
down a screen especially if he was
emotionally there for you and y'all were
like best friends and like really really
Partners you wouldn't leave Drake get
the [__] out of here nah you see me
right that's different not because it's
Drake you know what it is no the problem
is is that you're dating a bomb and you
feel like the the trade-off
is sexual exclusivity so when you find
out he's cheating on you that's the one
thing he was supposed to give up y'all's
relationship for you to be with him now
you find out his broke bomb ass is
cheating on you on top of that then
you're [__] pissed
woman you
will yourself
what do you mean men want an Untouchable
women most women have been touched by
many men
foreign
that's all I'm asking why would you want
that why would you want to be with a
girl that you know that's so everybody
else because they can hide it what are
you talking about in the relationship
he's got she's got to be faithful in the
relationships yeah Untouchable in that
sense but like your your past as well
like I don't know
men don't want women with a past like I
agree agreed but women want men with a
past
why not but you said you know there's a
difference between a virgin and an
absolute manner there's a difference
there's like a reason but if the man
knows that you don't want a manhole he
will just lie about his body count of
course yeah but let's be clear about the
guy that that's barely not a virgin it's
not because he doesn't want to be a man
[__] it's because he cannot achieve
such status so why would you want to so
you'd want to be with the guy that could
get other women because women don't want
men that other women don't want
yeah I agree so any guy that you deem as
high value whatever your criteria is
necessarily going to be a guy who has
had a past who has had other women
because otherwise hell of a past exactly
because otherwise his value is not gonna
he's not gonna mean anything but as a
woman you find that out about the guy
you're interested in it changes nothing
no the first thing that pop will pop
into a woman's head is so what's so
special about me then what's so special
about what like the girls who the girls
who sleep with Leonardo DiCaprio
probably nothing
I don't stand with those girls at all
because I think they're all silly you
know so when he's got the headphones on
he's listening to music and she's riding
him and he's just like looking at his
watch